dimanche 6 novembre 9h45 le départ de la
quatrième édition de la course royal
entre versailles fontenay-le-fleury sera
donné dans quelques minutes par les
organisateurs à la pièce de lait suisses
pour réaliser le meilleur chrono
possible et 800 participants inscrits
ont tous une stratégie va écouter au
feeling je vois je suis le parcours et
puis je me suis entraînée par la foule
et si c'était difficile sur la fin ben
je vais serrer les dents tout simplement
personnellement moi j'ai légère à un
niveau de tranquille entre 11 12 km
heure tranquille je sais qu'il ya là non
seulement celui qui avait la bonne
formule sur ce 10 km c'est lui habs
azzedine remporté la compétition pour la
deuxième fois consécutive en 32 minutes
et 34 secondes avec près de trois
minutes d'avancé sur le second d'agaléga
des as
quand je suis venu je suis venu pour
gagner c'est pas pour moi
ouais comme c'est c'est moi qui a gagné
l'année dernière on est un peu sur le 20
km jérôme tassin originaire de saint
rémy les chevreuse s'est imposé en une
heure 12 minutes et 46 secondes sa
première fois que je viens donc je sais
pas qui étaient les adversaires donc
voilà je suis parti dans un petit groupe
et qu'après au troisième kilomètre du
parti au troisième kilomètre j'ai pris
les commandes du 20 km et après j'ai pu
lâcher donc voila apres
psychologiquement je savais que de
garder le rythme chez les filles bat des
records la première féminine termine le
10 km ou quarante et une minutes et 24
secondes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour la
cinquième édition de la course 3 jan